and what could it be in terms of like
building something I've met with Jim
Simon's one-on-one for three hours it's
very eccentric guy brilliant as the day
is long all of modern neoclassical
economics is actually differential
geometric and three hours later he says
well Eric that's brilliant if you knew
what we were actually doing you'd be
very disciplined it's now a little while
later I don't know if you know who Brian
Keating is he's a professor at UCSD he's
an experimentalist
Jim is basically his uncle
the way you do this is we we get
together with a bunch of people we'd say
if Eric is correct or if somebody else
is correct and you started to play with
this extended model of both general
relativity and the standard model what
are some experiments we could run it's
one of the reasons I keep talking to
Brian Keating who's an experimentalist
because I want to talk to people who are
like how do how do we build this you're
the engineers of physics tell me what
tell me what I'm saying in terms that we
can build something and actually see if
it has